شمال ابقى معنا قالت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
نستشهاد الشيخ خضر عدنان لن يمر دون رد
واضافه الحركه ان المقاومه في وجه
الاحتلال ستتواصل بكل قوه واصرار وثبات
ينضم الينا من غزه داوود شهاب مسؤول
المكتب الاعلامي لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
سيد داوود شهاب استشهاد خدر عدنان هذا
اليوم ماذا يمثل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اولا
الشيخ القائد الحر قدر عدنان الذي ايضا
اليوم ينتصر
استشهاد الشيخ خبر عدنان هو انتصار للحريه
وانتصار للحق مواجهه الباطل
انتصار في مواجهه الحق في مواجهه الارهاب
الصهيوني نعم استشهد خبر عدنان لكن
المسيره لم تنتهي ولن تتوقف ووصيه الشيخ
خضر عدنان التي
ارسلها قبل ايام قليله او قبل تبيع من
استشهاده هي وصيه نحن نتمسك بها وهي وصيه
لنا ولكل ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني بمواصله
المقاومه ومواصله التصدي للاحتلال نعم اخي
الكريم اليوم
الى جماهير شعبنا وابناء امتنا العربيه
والاسلاميه رجلا عظيما من اشرف الرجال ومن
اعز
الرجال رجل عظيم وفارس عظيم للحسين فلسطين
وقائد كبير
عدنان الذي جابت ضفه الغربيه
وهو ينادي بحريه الشعب
وينادي بنصره المقدسات ونصره الاسرى خضر
عدنان الذي انحاز دائما الى الضعفاء الى
عوائل الشهداء والى هواءل الاسرى ولم يبقي
فلسطيني في الضفه الغربيه الا ودخله خضر
عدنان مساندا ومواسيا وداعما ومؤازرا
ومناظرا لكل قضيه حره في الضفه الغربيه
وفي كل شبر من فلسطين التي كان يستطيع ان
يصل اليها رغما عن الاحتلال الاحتلال حاول
محاوله خضر عدنان الاحتلال حاول قتل خبر
عدنان واليوم نفذ هذه الجريمه البشعه امام
العالم كله الجميع كل العالم كل الهيئات
الدوليه التي تتشدق بالحريه هي متواطئه
وشريكه في هذه الجريمه لانها لم تحرك
ساكنا لنصره خبر عدنان تحرك ساكنا لرفع
القمر
والاضطهاد الذي كان يمارس
الاحتلال بحق خضر عدنان
الاحتلال الصهيوني
والامنيه
ولا مصلحه السجون كل هذه المسميات كانت
زرع قذره
لقتل خضر عدنان ولمحافظ
ولابقائه داخل
السجون يعني لم يكن الاحتلال يعني يهدف
الى الا الى ابعاد خدر على المال يريد
الاحتلال قدر عثمان اما ان يبقى اسيرا او
شهيدا خبر عدنان الشهاده نعم هو اختار
الطريق والنهج الاصعب لكنه الاصوم في
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولذلك
هذه المسيره مسيره المقاومه ستبقى متواصله
سيتوجه خطر عدنان سيبقى حيا هل لديكم في
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي تفاصيل
استشهاده الساعات الاخيره كانت اخر
معلومات متوفره من المحاكمه التي اجلت يوم
الاحد ايضا
لظروفه الصحيه
لا هو الحقيقه نعم الاحتلال اجل المحاكمه
في مماطله واضحه وفي تسويف واضح انه كان
هناك يعني
جهود يمارسها الوسطاء
كانوا يمارسون ضغوطا ولديهم مع الاحتلال
بهدف انهاء معاناه الشيخ خضر عدنان
الاحتلال كان كل ذلك وابقى الشيخ خدران
داخل زنزانته يا اخي الكريم تخيل ان رجلا
مضربا عن الطعام منذ اكثر من 80 يوما
لم يتلقى اي مداعمات يبقى داخل زنزانه
يفقد الوعي داخل زنزانه بدون اي مرافقه
طبيه بدون ان يكون حتى على سرير في احد
المستشفيات داخل الاحتلال خبر عدنان وجد
فاقدا للوعي داخل زنزانه في سجون الاحتلال
وداخل زنزانه انفراديه هذا ما يجب ان يكون
واضحا ولذلك الجريمه هي الجريمه مكتمله
الاركان الجريمه هي جريمه واضحه مكتمله